today the Night wall show California's
creepiest groomer politician pulls a
Jessie Smollett and is perhaps the
dumbest and most blatant hoax of all
time also speaking of creepy groomers
Biden's BDSM dog fetishist energy
official gets put on administrative
leave a new film pushing gender ideology
on children is sponsored by
pharmaceutical companies I wonder why I
am persecuted by the audience despite
having fairly fulfilled the terms of my
anime deal and director James Cameron
warns that testosterone is a poison
quote unquote that must be purged out of
men all of that and more today on the
Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
versus Wade has been overturned and this
battle is now finally leaving D.C and
going to the Grassroots no group in
America is better positioned than 40
Days for life with about 1 million
Volunteers in a thousand cities 40 Days
for life holds peaceful vigils outside
of abortion facilities they have a
larger presence in blue states with
California being their largest state
some former abortion facility directors
say that these vigils can cause the
abortion no show rate to go as high as
75 which is detrimental to their
abortion business these law-abiding
vigils have closed many abortion
businesses in America and nearly half of
those closed abortion facilities were in
Liberal cities where abortion will
remain legal including closures in San
Francisco Chicago and Seattle 40 Days
for life is effectively changing hearts
and Minds in the Grassroots to end
abortion you can check out their
locations podcasts and free magazine at
40daysforlife.com and remember that now
is not the time to slow down or back
away in the fight for life it's never
been more important so for more
information on 40 Days for Life go to
40daysforlife.com
well there's been some renewed attention
this week on that parasitic organism
attached to the western part of the
nation known as California the state of
California is in many ways really a
tragic American story geographically
it's terrifically beautiful uh it was
discovered explored settled civilized
and conquered with great effort and
tremendous sacrifice over the course of
this country's early history it was once
one of our prize
possessions a sought after destination a
point of national pride and now that
pride has turned to shame it has become
a filthy grotesque cesspit basically the
country's septic tank is California its
cities smell like urine and weed
sidewalks covered in heroin needles and
human fecal matter violent homeless drug
addicts Rome the Lawless streets it's in
the midst of just total moral and
financial collapse
and this is all thanks to the psychotic
leftist regime that for so long has run
the state and is now running it all the
way into the ground which explains the
latest news out of California you may
have heard this reported by the daily
wire earlier this week quote thousands
of convicted pedophiles in California
served less than a year in prison after
committing lewd or lascivious acts with
a child under 14 years old according to
an investigative
report The Daily Mail analyzed a
Statewide database of sex offenders that
showed more than seven thousand child
molesters were released within months
after Federal authorities sentenced them
to prison former Los Angeles sex crimes
prosecutor Samuel door to Leon told
Daily Mail that the statistics shocked
him adding that the reality is
frightening for society statistics
clearly show that pedophiles don't get
reformed he said they're going to come
out and they're going to commit again
letting these people out early were
allowing for a lot more victimization
and that's terrifying California law
requires sex offenders to register their
address and update their location upon
moving with the Department of Justice
those names and other personal details
are then placed in a public database
under Megan's Law which the Clinton
Administration passed in 1996 after a
pedophile murdered seven-year-old Megan
kanka according to the report 54 986
offenders were listed on the website in
July 2019 of which 76 per percent
committed offenses involving children
the average pedophile served two years
sorry two years and 10 months in prison
so almost got up to three years but not
quite
now the report of the Daily Mail also
provides specific examples naming names
and the crimes they committed back to
the Daily wire it says one of the
examples outlined in the Daily Mail
report said that an offender in the
database named Carlos
Alexander nahu 48 of Rosetta California
lives one block from Royal Montessori
School daycare and three blocks from
Rosetta elementary school after
allegedly being convicted of continuous
sexual abuse of a child in 2015.
authorities charged nahu in October 2014
he pled no contest to the crime in
January 2015 which resulted in a judge
sentencing him to only two days
in the Los Angeles County jail and five
years of probation
two days
I mean you could spend more time in jail
for like a DUI
and this was the continuous sexual abuse
of a child
which by the way this is why I have a
problem with the sex offender registry
as a concept
because if you're telling me that
someone has been convicted of a sex
crime and is a danger to offend again
which is the point of the registry
that's what necessitates the registry to
let people know oh this dangerous person
is out there and keeping kids away from
them well if that's the case then this
is someone who should not be released
from prison in the first place
so the registry shouldn't exist because
anyone who needs to be on it should
simply be locked behind bars and then
he's not our problem and we don't need
to have his name on the registry
it's like we don't release serial
killers from prison and then put their
names on a serial killer registry you
know you don't put the serial killers
back in the community and then say hey
just say no here's a map with the red
dots and those were all the serial
killers are
you keep them in prison
so why are we doing that with sex
Predators why are they being released in
the first place
well this is no surprise in California
they believe that it is cruel and unjust
to punish violent criminals so instead
they punish law-abiding citizens by
putting them in a position to be
victimized by the violent criminals
and when it comes to Violent criminals
California has a special soft spot for
predators and groomers after all this is
a state run by such people as Charlie
Kirk pointed out in a tweet thread
yesterday one of the most powerful and
influential lawmakers in the state is a
guy named Scott weiner that's a name you
may recall because well it's funny but
also because weiner is The Man Behind
Some of the most horrifically insane
pieces of legislation this country has
ever seen
running through a few of them for
example back in 2017 weiner authored a
bill
to reduce the penalties for those who
knowingly and intentionally expose a sex
partner to HIV without telling them
so because of Weiner's legislation
willfully transmitting a deadly STD to
another person is now a misdemeanor
offense it used to be a felony and you
get three to eight years in prison
if you willingly expose someone to HIV
and don't tell them that you have it
you can go to prison in the past you go
to prison for up to eight years for that
um he defended the law the law that uh
that gets rid of those penalties and
makes a misdemeanor by insisting that
well modern Medical Treatments have
dramatically lengthened the lives of
those suffering from HIV is what he said
so so don't worry he says if somebody
willfully infects you with the virus
it's okay because your life will likely
be shortened but not shortened by as
much as it used to be
and this is a sacrifice that you should
be happy to make for the sake of
allowing those with HIV to have
unencumbered sex because of course in
the in the eyes of somebody like Scott
Weiner and uh and really anyone else on
the left that it's just it is a it is an
unthinkable
form of Oppression
to tell someone that they should
exercise any
um
uh caution or that there should be any
restrictions at all on their sex life
the only point of living is just to have
unencumbered sex all the time with
whoever you want whenever you want
that's the way that he looks at it
and so if people die in pursuit of that
then it's it's a it is a sacrifice worth
making
weiner the same man who recently
suggested that grade schools should have
mandatory drag queen 101 classes also
spearheaded a Bill signed into law a few
weeks ago making California into a
sanctuary State quote unquote for child
gender transition so parents who live in
states where mutilation and castration
on minors has been banned they can
kidnap their children and bring their
children to the West Coast where they
could be offered up as human sacrifices
on the altar of gender ideology
and if you've got a situation where one
parent wants to abuse their child in
this way and the other parent
desperately is trying to save their
child from that kind of abuse well again
the the parent the abusive parent can
just kidnap the child bring them to uh
to California and this will happen and
as part of this law California has said
that um
you know uh that there if other states
are trying to arrest the parent doing
this that California is not going to
cooperate with that
now that's not to say that weiner
considers parental involvement a
necessity when it comes to Medical
Treatments quote unquote Medical
Treatments last year after all he wrote
legislation permitting children as young
as 12
to get the vaccine in the coveted
vaccine without parental consent
so protecting children is certainly not
among wieners priorities in 2020 perhaps
most infamously
the California state Senate's most
prolific groomer Scott weiner pushed
through a bill to end quote
discrimination against adults who have
gay sex with minors
the law gives discretion to judges in
cases where an adult engages in sodomy
with a child who's at least 14 and no
more than 10 years younger than himself
so for example
a 24 year old man who abuses a 14 year
old boy
would potentially benefit from Weiner's
legislation weiner was saying we don't
want to discriminate against the
Predator in that case
so this is in other words a deeply evil
man and we haven't even mentioned his
recent Bill ensuring that convicted
violent male criminals
will be housed with women if they claim
to be women themselves and in light of
recent events I think the defense that
he offered this is at a town hall
actually a recent Town Hall where he's
defending this idea that we should if a
convicted male criminal says I'm a woman
you put him in lock him in a cage with
uh
actual women and he defends I want you
to listen to what he says because as I
said in re in light of recent events
this is kind of interesting listen
unfortunately there's been a right-wing
backlash against this law and we have
right-wing Publications that are
publishing a lot of
um just inaccurate information
effectively fake news
um about uh about this law and trying to
demonize and scapegoat trans people
um including uh unfortunately
um there's a term called Turf
transexclusive radical feminist
um people who believe that trans women
are not actually women
um and uh and advocate in that way they
blockaded the London Pride Parade
um the protest trans people being
included in the pride parade
um and so it's just very unfortunate
these anti-transgender attacks and so
they're claiming that trans women are
gonna are actually not real women and or
men trying to scam their way into
women's prison to victimize women these
are the same arguments we heard in the
North Carolina restroom law that trans
women are just trying to scam their away
into a women's restroom to victimize
cisgender women it's really unfortunate
but we're going to continue to work just
to really support all of our
marginalized communities here in
California
support the marginalized communities
except for the women who are in prison
and have basically no rights and have no
ability to speak out and no way to
defend themselves so that's not a
marginalized Community is interested in
defending but he does say it's an
outlandish right-wing conspiracy theory
that a man might claim to be a woman
purely to manipulate and gain the system
And yet when the Colorado Springs gay
club shooter last week revealed his own
non-binary status the left immediately
assumed that he was claiming that
identity purely to manipulate and game
the system
so on one hand that would never happen
they would never do that and then well
except in this case
the self-contradiction here seems
indefensible so how do they defend it
indeed how does someone like Scott
weiner defend any of what I've just laid
out
well like this so last night weiner who
I should remind you is an elected
lawmaker
tweeted this
quote not even 24 hours after Maga
grifter Charlie Kirk tweeted homophobic
lies about me and The Lies by the way
were just accurately laying out the
bills that he has supported and authored
and pushed through anyway I received
this threat repeating one of his lies
but that was the point riling people up
against me and other lgbtq people words
have consequences and Twitter is
becoming a cesspool for this crap he
does know a lot about cesspools after
all he lives in one and then provides a
screenshot of this death threat and
here's what the death threat says
quoting it's a shame you come out and
you're trying to release all these
pedophiles you're okay with people
intentionally giving other people AIDS
and your office can't even pick up the
phone to answer about these questions
you're sick man I don't even call you
you shouldn't even be a man you're a
sick individual I don't care about what
you do off hours but when you try to
force it upon California it's like
myself and others you'll have you'll
have something coming to you people like
you won't be able to walk down the
streets when light comes to the darkness
that you're effing providing you piece
of s
okay now there is one problem here aside
from how incoherent all that is
the problem is that as you can see in
the screenshot he provides
the cursor
is is clearly visible you can see the
cursor in the screenshot which obviously
shows that he wrote the threat himself
you can also see the spell check
underlines indicating grammatical errors
of which there are many in that uh fake
dead threat
which is obviously not something that
appears on a message or email that you
receive from somebody else that's only
there if you're writing it
I mean at this point I'm only surprised
that he didn't accidentally sign the
message with his own name
maybe sign it sincerely Scott Weiner and
then cross it out and write some other
name and still post it
this is not only a hoax but perhaps the
laziest hoax we've seen yet
which is really saying something
it just it continues to honestly amaze
me that the left invents so many hoaxes
and relies so heavily on them and yet
still hasn't figured out how to make
them even mildly believable
they also haven't developed convincing
Alibis some hours after this original
tweet was posted and after conservatives
started mocking him ruthlessly for it he
tweeted this follow-up and by the way
but speaking of conservatives mocking
him for it this thing was was posted
and uh and it took a few hours because
you know conservatives we don't
typically check Scott Weiner's Twitter
so I think it took a few hours to even
notice it and in the intervening hours
you know his own supporters were just
commenting and say oh that's terrible I
can't believe they would say that when
the cursor is visible in the screenshot
they either are too stupid to notice
that or just were willing to look over
it and I think it's probably more the
latter although some of the former two
so after conservatives noticed it he he
then tweeted a follow-up he said for all
the mega conspiracy theorists out there
the threat was a voicemail this is a
transcription but have fun spinning
around with your conspiracies
sure so someone calls in a death threat
to his personal phone to his office he
doesn't specify
and rather than post the audio of the
call which you could easily do
he writes out a transcript
and then post that instead and doesn't
mention that it was a voicemail until
everyone doubts his original story
who could believe who could disbelieve
rather such a tale
well anybody with a brain which means
that he's pretty safe in California of
course
now in Another Universe it it might be
shocking
that a sitting state senator
would casually and so blatantly invent a
death threat as a means of silencing and
and his opposition really silencing and
defaming another person who he names
but in this universe it's exactly what
we've come to expect
emotionalism is the only argument these
people know
self-victimization is their only
rhetorical strategy
and the truth of course is irrelevant
Jesse weiner may not have actually been
the victim of this death threat but but
you know at some level he feels like he
was
and in our culture of course there's no
difference between truth and feelings
now let's get to our five headlines
are you struggling to reach your fitness
goals as it turns out having world-class
instructors plus a community of hundreds
of thousands of people who are working
towards the same goal really helps the
guys at Echelon Fitness have it all
worked out Echelon Fitness is the the
affordable way to get workout equipment
a community a workout community and an
instructor's motivation right in the
comfort and privacy of your own home
Echelon fitness's Connected app provides
thousands of Live And on-demand classes
with great music to keep you moving you
can work out anytime day or night their
full range of affordable workouts
equipment includes stationary bikes
smart rower Sleek Fitness screens and an
auto folding treadmill these are all
connected to the echelon fitness app for
The Full Experience Around the Clock
classes including full body workout
programs will keep you coming back one
membership covers a family of five so
for a limited time my audience can get a
free bike or rowing machine with a
24-month membership to get your free
bike or rower text mat to 818181 that's
Matt to 818181 to claim your free bike
or rowing machine text Matt to 8
818181 message and data rates may apply
C terms for details
all right I almost don't even want to
move past that because it's so I I feel
like I should spend I won't don't worry
but I it's worth an entire show it's
like worth an entire week of shows I we
faking a death threat and then taking a
screenshot with the cursor still visible
it's one of the greatest
is one of the funniest things I think
that's that I've ever seen it's just
it's incredible but then what makes it
so depressing is that it's also sort of
as I said not incredible it's it's it
should be more incredible than it is
and since we're on the subject of uh of
hoaxes now I was thinking about this
if I just saw someone tweet about it
last night before the uh before
um Scott uh smallett leapt into action
but you may remember a couple weeks ago
in fact during the daily cancellation I
mentioned this story about a noose that
was discovered at the a so-called news
was discovered at the Obama Presidential
Center construction site in Chicago and
they're still because it you know
because of all the red tape and
bureaucracy it takes 65 years to build
anything anymore and they're still
working they're not even like they're
they're barely passed uh you know
they're still in the early stages of
building his presidential Center and the
story was that and this was back on
there's a CNN report this is back on
November 11th
the story is that somebody found a noose
at the construction site and they shut
everything down and everybody involved
was issuing apologies and the mayor and
the governor spoke out and they
condemned it and said this is an act of
hate
and then as we talked about daily
cancellation you know far be it for me
to to cast to any doubt whatsoever on a
story like this but I I did point out
that um of course we we hear about
nooses being discovered all the time and
in in in literally every single case I
mean as in 100 of the time it turns out
to be a hoax or either a deliberate hoax
or someone a very stupid person just
sees an innocent rope like a bubble a
Bubba Wallace situation uh and that was
you know how to what level was that his
stupidity versus deliberate you know
that's we could debate it someone sees
an innocent rope and then misinterprets
it but that's 100 time it's one of those
two things
um and then I also pointed out how this
actually happens a lot
in construction sites there's like been
this in the media is reported on it this
rash this mysterious epidemic of nooses
being found on construction sites
happens a lot entire construction
projects are shut down because someone
finds a news
and then what do you then what what do
you know a few weeks later it turns out
that oh well it was just a rope because
this is a construction site and a rope
is a tool that is often used in
construction
and sometimes believe it or not the
ropes will be tied into like some kind
of a knot
and also believe it or not not every
knot is a noose there are other forms of
knots you learn this if you were
in the Boy Scouts which I wouldn't
recommend being in the Boy Scouts
anymore
going back to the Obama Presidential
Center so this was two weeks ago
everything was shut down because of this
hate crime news
there was a one hundred thousand dollar
reward offered
for information about the news
two weeks later we've heard nothing
about it I just looked up for for an
update I went to Google searched any
news article that's been written about
in the past week and nothing
nothing
and this is the way that it always goes
it's gonna be the same thing with the
death threat to uh to Scott weiner
we hear about it and then oh this is
terrible condemnations and we're gonna
look into this we're going to
investigate and then that's the less you
ever hear about
all right
here's another update on a on a story uh
this is from The Daily Mail as well
it says the bite administration's
non-binary nuclear waste Guru was a
presenter at a fetish conference in La
weeks after admitting to stealing a
woman's suitcase at the Minneapolis-St
Paul International Airport last Saturday
Sam Britton Deputy assistant Secretary
of the office of spent Fuel and waste
disposition who could be facing five
years in prison for the bag theft
presented a seminar titled spanking
from calculus to chemistry
the seminar was held at West End
Bonaventure Hotel in Suites in Los
Angeles where of course in Los Angeles
where Britain 34 stayed on Friday and
Saturday night the event was titled La
leather getaway and was sponsored by
claw Corporation a national leather
charity
a national leather charity
so is this like they donate leather
bondage gear
to BDSM fans in need is that is that
what this is
Britain who presented at the event under
the pseudonym nuclear nerd has been
teaching their their has been teaching
their physics of Kink class at
universities and communities events
across the country for years according
to their profile on Clause website
the bio goes on to say they have been
active in the Kink world since 2013 they
host monthly Kink parties in their
dungeon in Washington DC and estimate
that they have spanked over 2 000 butts
I'm regretting even reading this
so he actually he's keeping a body count
of the number of uh asses that he has
spanked
and this person was given a position a a
high ranking position let's not forget
in the department of energy
and given I believe
don't quote me on this the highest
security clearance available to somebody
in the department or one of the highest
at the very least
um now we should note that the other
update to the story is that he has been
placed on leave
after this incident was stealing the bag
but that's revealing on a couple of
levels because uh number one the bag was
stolen and the police found out about it
and and charges were filed weeks ago
this all happened weeks ago it's not
until the public finds out that the by
Administration places this person on
leave
but it's also revealing because so it's
stealing a woman's bag which which yes
is is bad and creepy on many levels
especially because we know why he stole
it was was almost certainly to steal the
clothes and wear the woman's clothing
because he's a freak
um yeah that's that's bad but that's
what gets him placed on leave
yeah the fact that he runs a sex dungeon
in Washington DC that that's not enough
to do it
going and attending uh or or rather
hosting and teaching at fetish classes
and giving spanking classes that that's
not enough to make you second guess
um no of course not
you know there was now one thing of
course is that Sam Britton is certainly
not the first deviant fetishist to work
in Washington DC are we gonna We can
certainly say that he absolutely is not
the first
the difference is that he's so open
about it
and that we're supposed to celebrate
this
and this is what happens when you know
you we are forced as we talked about a
few days ago to
not just affirm someone's
self-perceptions and self-identity as
bad as that is
but now we have to go even further and
we're told we have to affirm even
someone's fetish
their you know sexual deviances and all
the rest of it
all right a couple of weeks ago the New
York Times published an article
questioning the use of puberty blockers
for children and uh we talked about that
on the show and and of course they were
not outright condemning the use of
puberty blockers as they should
obviously but they were questioning it
and that is at least some amount of
progress
it's not progress that we should
congratulate the New York Times for when
they're a decade late to the party and
they still lack the courage to come just
come and outright say what they
obviously know to be true which is that
we should not be doing this to any kids
at all
instead they said you know certainly
there are times when this is necessary
and it's uh this is a medical procedure
that's approved by many but there are
questions we should be asking questions
now the world um
the W path which is the the biggest
transgender Health Organization in the
world they have finally responded it
took them a couple weeks but they
finally responded
to that New York Times article
and they issued a lengthy statement I'm
not going to read the entire thing
because there's no reason really to read
it most of of uh of their article just
centers around questioning the
credentials of the people who are quoted
in the New York Times article
because that's all these people can ever
do that's always what it comes down to
right every single argument comes down
to credentialism appeals to Authority so
that's all they did for for most of
their uh of their response
but then there's this part I want you to
listen to this
wpath says
the blockers themselves do not impact
bone density
this is one of the big claims accurate
claims that the New York Times made in
that article is that it has it has it
damages bones it damages bone density
and all the rest but they say the
blockers themselves do not impact bone
density
bone density is impacted by the fact
that sex steroid production is
temporarily halted when puberty blockers
are initiated
now hang on a second let's go back and
read that again because I'm a little
confused
the blockers themselves do not impact
bone density
bone density is impacted by the fact
that sex steroid production is
temporarily halted when puberty blockers
are initiated
in other words
they do impact punt density
I'll go back to that second let's keep
reading the Adolescent in this anecdote
was already using estrogen which
promotes bone health therefore the point
about stopping blockers due to bone
density loss is moot many types of
blockers are routinely used in
combination with estrogen well through
adulthood without deleterious effects on
bone density this has been the common
practice for treatment of adult
transgender individuals for decades but
for of adult notice they're saying adult
bone density loss is generally not a
concern once hormone therapy has begun
in fact Dr kosla's paper states that
quote
the skeleton should be relatively well
protected assuming adequate compliance
with hormone therapy
now that in and of itself is not ex
doesn't sound to me to be a ringing
endorsement of puberty blockers well the
skeletons should be relatively well
protected
what kind of parent what what kind of
what kind of sane and actually loving
parent could hear that from a doctor and
then decide to go through with it anyway
yes we're going to give your child this
medically unnecessary uh drug for
cosmetic reasons and as far as their
bones you know your child's bones his
skeleton should be relatively well
protected
but going back to the very beginning
this this is the game that these people
play and they and they they get away
with it
because of course no one in the
corporate media nobody on the left is
going to criticize them or put them
under any scrutiny and a lot of people
in the right are too afraid to and so
they get away with this kind of thing
and it is it is outrageous
they get away with making the claim this
is not going to be fact check you know
Twitter's not fact checking and this is
this is not this is not going to go
through any of the fact Checkers and
this is not going to be misinformation
context needed no this is they're
allowed to say this
not only that but actually this is going
to be used I guarantee it maybe not on
Twitter anymore I hope not but certainly
on Facebook and the other platforms this
statement from wpath will be used to
fact check conservatives when who are
criticizing gender ideology they're not
going to take this statement rather than
fact checking the statement the
statement itself will be used as a fact
check against people who are criticizing
gender ideology
and yet what are they saying here the
blockers don't impact bone density
bone density is impacted by the fact
that steroid production is temporarily
halted so
the blockers don't impact density but
the the blockers have an effect on the
body
which then impacts bone density
so it's not the blockers themselves are
impacting bonus it's what the blocker is
doing to the body that impacts bone
density now you may ask what the hell is
the distinction there there is no
distinction
okay this is not even a distinction it's
just a different way of phrasing the
exact same thing
and again they get away with it
all right
uh meanwhile Christopher rufo has this
report it says the new animated film for
kids mama has a mustache is sponsored by
Abby V which is the pharmaceutical
company that sells the chemical
castration drug Lupron to convicted
pedophiles and quote transgender
children a little bit more on this um
animated film which is sponsored not
just by this pharmaceutical company but
by others as well but first let's watch
the uh I guess this is the trailer for
this
piece of propaganda watch
can you be a girl and have a boy body or
be a boy and have a girl body yes
can this person be a parent yes my dad
[Music]
I feel like I'm not really a boy or a
girl
[Music]
mama has a mustache mommy has a mustache
by the way I was curious about the film
itself this propaganda film and um
I tried it went to look up where where
can you find it
um
not that it's a a something that I would
enjoy watching but it is something that
I'm I'm interested to see for the
purposes of debunking it and uh you it's
it's not available like you have to
they kind of keep it under lock and key
they're not making it widely available
to everybody which is uh
not a surprise because that's exactly
what they don't want exactly what they
don't want is someone like me watching
it and going through to picking up
picking it apart
um so you can access it but you gotta go
you gotta sign you have to basically
fill like an application form to access
the film
although we've seen enough from it just
based on that
uh and it it will never fail to just
absolutely disgust and infuriate me when
uh
I see any kind of propaganda like this
but especially you know you hear the
child
you're one of the children one of the
abused children being exploited for this
thing
say uh well I I love myself
which is good
right because you should love yourself
and we should teach our kids our
children to love themselves and accept
themselves for who they are
um that's an important message
because the other option is
self-loathing the other option is to
reject to want to reject who you
naturally are
and yes we should be we should be
teaching our kids to love themselves but
that is is exactly
what this kind of propaganda does not
teach
teaches the opposite
under the guise of loving yourself it
actually teaches kids to hate themselves
to hate who they are
to to try to destroy who they actually
are with drugs and surgery if necessary
for the sake of obtaining some kind of
image an image that they didn't even
come up with an image that was given to
them by the propagandists by the
groomers
uh Breitbart has more on this story it
says a pro-transgender propaganda film
for children called Mama has a mustache
was sponsored by bear a um a
pharmaceutical company that produces
drugs that are used to feminize men who
identify as transgender
mama has a mustache is all about
normalizing transgenderism particularly
in the minds of one group of people and
that is young children the film's
website Bears the phrase kids talk
gender directly above the trailer which
starts with a child being asked can you
be a girl and have a boy body or be a
boy and a girl body we heard that
um
the synopsis of mama has a mustache
leaves no room for doubt about the
film's intentions to mold the minds of
young children the film is driven
completely by Audio interviews of kids
ages 5 to 10 and explores how children
are able to experience a world outside
of the traditional gender binary
and of course we're supposed to be
getting uh the child's perspective but
we're not actually getting the child's
perspective we're getting the child
these children repeating the propaganda
that's been fed to them so we're getting
adult
disseminated propaganda fed through the
mouths of children
kids didn't come up with anything kids
didn't come up with with the gender
identity kids didn't come up with the
idea that you could be a boy a girl in a
boy's body no no child developed that
idea that was developed by the groomers
and the Predators and kids are being
made to repeat it
but the point here is that you've got it
seems at least two pharmaceutical
companies
that are behind this film that have
helped to sponsor it
um
and we see again where the lefts uh you
know their the this pose they strike of
being critical of Corporations and
skeptical of big money influence and all
of that all of that reveals itself to be
just that oppose it's all that's all it
is
I wish it were true
you know and I think for a long time the
right bought into this too much they
bought into this uh you know this this
notion that the left is like demonizing
corporations and demonizing rich people
and I think simply demonizing
corporations demonizing rich people is
simplistic
but I wish that it was true I wish that
that was I wish that was the mistake the
left made being overly simplistic in
their in their condemnations of money
and rich people and corporations
I wish that was true
but it's not true at all of course
because if you are going to be skeptical
of
billion dollar corporations
um the first place you should be looking
and the first place where you should be
directing that skepticism is to the
pharmaceutical industry
doesn't mean all all drugs that uh the
pharmaceutical industry produces are bad
necessarily
I think a lot of them are they're not
all bad
but this is a multi-billion dollar
industry that um
makes all that money
not just by not just by uh
treating sickness
but by convincing people they are sick
so that they can then treat it
and this comes in many forms and it
includes most nefariously
and insidiously the you know convincing
children that they're sick with this
gender dysphoria so then can be treated
by the drugs they provide
all right let's see there's one other
thing I wanted to mention before we get
to the comment section
daily wire has this story Kathleen
cassillo is a mother of three from
Queens New York it was Christmas
shopping with her daughter in Manhattan
on December 11 2020
when she drove up to an intersection
filled with protesters blocking the road
to impose to oppose rather U.S
immigration Customs Enforcement
detentions
on Tuesday she again rejected a plea
deal that would admit fault but only
requires six hours of community service
and a one-year license suspension
or probably Castillo instead has opted
for a jury trial where she faces seven
years in prison if found guilty she
rejected the same plea deal last year
according to New York Post
in video footage that captured part of
the incident casio's black BMW can be
seen surrounded by protests or some of
whom appear to be touching or banging on
her vehicle casillo then stepped on the
gas and sped through the group injuring
nine
casillo told the mail last year my side
of the story was we were attacked by
people who were going to break my
daughter's window and pull her out of
the car so I feared for my life
I'm going to court to clear my name
because I'm not guilty I feel sick she
continued I never intended on hurting
anyone I just feared for my daughter's
life more than anybody I thought they
were going to pull her out of the car
and and uh and rightfully so did she
fear for her daughter's life I mean it's
it's not as though there's there are no
examples of that happening
I think this this woman I don't know
anything else anything else about it
besides what I just read in the article
but this is this is like
just take some real courage
because they they're they're saying okay
six hours of community service will
suspend your license that's not a small
deal to get your license suspended but
she's willing to she's going to turn
that down she's willing to risk years in
prison
for the sake of clearing her name
and standing by the truth
uh it's a real risk there but it takes a
lot of guts takes a lot of Courage
and you have to respect that and I think
it also shows you
that you know the prosecutors realize
they don't have a case like if they
thought they had a case and that this
woman really was just some crazed
lunatic uh guilty of uh you know
attempted murder essentially plowing
down protesters or whatever but they
thought they thought they had any way of
winning that then they would be charging
with that but instead they're offering
her six hours of community service
because they know they don't have a case
um and even if she's innocent which is
clear to me that she is does that mean
that she'll actually be found not guilty
in court well
that of course remains to be seen
but in reality
you know first of all
nobody has any right to block a roadway
you don't have any right to do that
okay
um it's not like she's driving the car
into your into the front of your house
you're sitting in your living room and
you get hit
they're sitting blocking the road they
have no right to do that now these
left-wing protesters have been empowered
in this way and have been told that they
have the right to just you know block
invade restaurants burn things down loot
whatever block blocking a road is the
least of it
and the more they're in power the more
it leads to incidents like this
but they don't actually have any right
to do that and when you're being
surrounded by this hostile group of
maniacs
then you have every right to fear for
your life this is this is a
life-threatening situation you have a
child in the car
absolutely step on the gas
without hesitation
that's the right move all right let's
get now to the comment section
[Music]
today
we're the sweet baby gang
a hard year on the economy means that
essential practical gifts will be in
high demand this year you can give the
most essential gift of all America's
best meat and seafood from good Ranchers
with discounts on orders of five boxes
or more you can save on gifts for the
whole family when you give a box of good
ranchers you're giving them a true
Steakhouse experience with 100 American
USDA prime and uppercut Choice choices
of uh of a beef Chicken and Seafood
other meat delivery companies and even
your local grocery store Imports lower
Quality Meat from overseas don't give
your friends and family less than
America's best this year not sure what
to order well good ranchers now offers
gift cards so you can let your friends
and family members choose for themselves
or you can give the gift of a
subscription and inflation proves
someone's meat budget at the same time
go to goodranchors.com and use code wall
should check out to get 35 off your gift
that's goodranchors.com code walls for
35 off good ranchers American Meat
delivered
you know uh my wife the one thing about
her is that she doesn't like to make
things easy on herself and um
I've never quite understood this you
know I don't know if it's a if there's a
little bit of the
a gender difference here or what but
um because I keep trying to tell her
like make life easier on yourself to any
extent that you can we're gonna have six
kids now so the life's difficulty
setting is already
I'm not gonna say it's hot as high as
you can get but it's already pretty high
like six kids all under the age of nine
all nine and under that's a pretty high
difficulty setting um I don't think you
need to you know you don't need to
complicate it any more than it already
is and that's been what I'm always
preaching but it doesn't always resonate
so
um she chooses the hard way sometimes so
so like for instance yesterday last
night put the kids down for bed
and um she comes into the living room
and she's all like exhausted I mean
she's she's very pregnant at this point
with twins so she's exhausted she's
exasperated and I asked her what's wrong
and she said well I had to move the
elves around
and I said elves and she said yeah elf
on a shelf and I said oh great we're
doing that again and then I said but
what do you mean is Elf on a Shelf a
singular Elf on a Shelf and she said oh
no no it's it's see what she informed me
is that is that this year
for reasons that have still not been
explained
each of our kids have their own elf they
each have their own Elf on a Shelf
and I'm not making this up this is this
is real
the elves also have pets
so this is a thing now with the Elf on
the Shelf thing you got the elves and
then the elves have their own have like
little puppies
and so we've got four elves for all the
kids that are for all the born children
I'm surprised you didn't get two for The
Unborn children too and then the elves
have pets and so the elves have to move
and the pets have to be moved
every night for the next month
and I was just trying to ask her why
would you do this what what why well
it's fun for the kids yeah it's but it's
not even that fun
yeah it's fun for the kids but you have
to measure that it's the the misery and
uh hassle for you versus fun for the
kids and you know it's sometimes fun for
the kids wins out but you we gotta
strike a balance here
the other thing too is I don't even
think the older kids believe the elf
thing anymore
I'm almost certain they know that we're
the ones well not me I don't do it I'm
I'm almost certain they know that my
wife is the one moving the elf around
but they just enjoy the spectacle so
they're letting her continue to do it
and
my god
um all right
Philip has this
LOL how quickly people forget that Bob
Iger was the one who started pouring uh
started this is small you started
pouring on the woke at full speed before
leaving who thinks this was a victory
uh
that's why I said Phil that it's it's it
this is not a complete Victory you know
the the clips we played of Bob Iger is
the new CEO the old CEO and now the new
CEO of Disney
seemingly sort of backing away from the
from uh from politics and backing away
from this war between Disney and
DeSantis
so I said it's not an absolute total
final Victory I'm under No Illusion that
uh Disney is going to become anti-woke
or conservative or start churning out
all this conservative content nobody's
saying that but they are backing away
from the fight okay and that is a it's a
it's a victory in the battle
and there's nothing wrong with
acknowledging that I think as
conservatives actually that's something
we should be doing more often
I don't want to rest on your laurels you
have a victory you don't want to just
kind of
congratulate yourself and then give up
at that point and and think that the war
is over but when there is a a win
however minor it's it's a good thing to
acknowledge that
as opposed to this kind of Doom saying
that I certainly can be guilty of quite
often where it's just like there's never
any Victory is nothing is ever any good
nothing is we're always losing
I think after a while becomes a
defeatist mentality and uh
that's what I'm worried about here all
right
Ed says clarification for Matt not long
ago a close friend of mine went to a
hospital for a non-coveted related
health problem he was taken to the ER
for some reason and then assigned a bed
elsewhere in the hospital turns out it
was the coveted Ward that needed to fill
the coveted word for financial reasons
when he said he was leaving the hospital
security Force
whatever that is said that they would
stop my friend for his own good finally
one lawyer and two ex-military friends
later my friend left the hospital and
the staff cursed him and hurled insults
please do not trust the police or anyone
to determine who needs to go to the
hospital
yeah and there were a few comments like
this uh relating to you know New York
City has said that it's now going to
start
um
involuntarily committing mentally ill
dangerous mentally ill people and this
was uh my point Ed as well that yeah
it's it's on the surface in theory
that's the right thing to do we used to
have mental asylums that used to be a
thing and there's a place for those in
society because there are crazy people
out there who are dangerous and um we're
either going to protect society and
protect them from themselves by
committing them or just going to allow
them to run free you know in the streets
and we see what that happens in places
what happens because of that in places
like New York but the fear is that um
you're entrusting this power to the
government and especially a government
like the one that runs New York
um
and it's easy to see how that could be
abused
when they get to determine what
constitutes a mental illness and what
constitutes a danger to society
uh
Joe says your ability to weasel your way
out of an uncomfortable commitment on a
ridiculous technicality is admirable
thank you Joe Elizabeth says we have to
stop letting Matt get out of his deals
on technicalities Landon says come on
Matt that was a bit of a cop-out I
really need to see internet dad watch a
season of Japan's finest
okay I I know look
I know you're not satisfied I get it
there are a lot of comments like that
some people in fact were very upset
um I did yesterday I did watch a season
of anime so that according maybe not the
spirit of the deal but according to the
letter of the law the letter you know
what we signed on the dotted line
I I fulfilled my obligation
but here's the good news
if that wasn't good enough for you
somebody else another member of the SBG
has made a different anime and this one
is literally twice as long as the one
yesterday okay twice as long that's how
long it is twice as long
and I think that you will agree that if
we watch this one together
it will fulfill my responsibility and my
obligation and I will have lived up to
my end of the deal so this is called The
Adventures of a matsuman and uh which
you can you can find this on on
YouTube's wonderful uh anime video and
this is a you know this is an anime and
well let's watch it go ahead
laughs
[Music]
the card away it's really not that
difficult
[Music]
oh it's a season one episode one except
it
that so the the the this person didn't
understand the excitement completes but
that's supposed to be the entire season
but but still I I thought look I
actually do is that these are just two
anime shows now two in a row that I
personally really like and I thought
that I thought the voice acting first of
all in this one was tremendous
um as much as I loved the anime from
yesterday I thought this one uh I
thought the plot was uh was even more
absorbing
and it was a little bit long for my
taste it kind of I felt that it dragged
just a little bit uh had some slower
Parts but but it also you know you got
it you gotta you have to slow down the
pace a little bit too to get more
absorbed into the story and
um I thought that the character Arc was
was really well executed I just thought
it was really really good so yet again
I'm gonna give that uh an A plus and so
I have now fulfilled my obligation not
once but twice
and if that's not good enough for you
then I don't know what to tell you
the season of giving is officially upon
us but as you shop holiday gifts of uh
and Deals you should ask yourself
who exactly are you giving to because if
you're buying stocking stuffers from
woke companies you're really just
stuffing the pockets of leftist CEOs and
paying them to mock your values don't
give them your money give Jeremy your
money his brand new collection of
Jeremy's razor products will make the
perfect gift for the pronounless men in
your life and today is the last day of
his 30 percent uh cyber sale so get your
loved one some woke free shampoo and
conditioner body wash beard kit or the
new Precision 5 razor with flip back
trimmer before Jeremy merrily restores
list pricing so go to Jeremy's
racers.com for your last chance to save
now let's get to our daily cancellation
foreign
films then um You probably don't need
any additional incentive to not watch
the upcoming sequels from director James
Cameron who hasn't made a decent film in
about I guess it's been probably 20
years
of course the original Avatar back in 29
2009 was a a massive
multi-billion dollar hit but that was
due mostly to this period of mass
societal psychosis that caused millions
of people to believe temporarily that it
was a good film it was very bewildering
time for people like myself who never
fell under this hypnotic trance
um eventually though everyone woke up
from their hallucinogenic stupor and
realized that Avatar was despite the
special effects one of the least
interesting and least inventive films
ever released
it was essentially just Disney's
Pocahontas but with blue people and less
singing it was a film so lacking in wit
and creativity that the natural resource
that everyone is fighting over in the
film now it centers around this natural
resource
and it's called unobtainium because you
know it's difficult to obtain
that that's the level of writing we got
in this film it was the kind of film
where the bad guy is an evil army
officer with a scar on his face who's
motivated to do bad things because you
know he's the evil bad guy and that's
what evil guys do and I would continue
in my critique of the movie but it was
so utterly forgettable that there isn't
much else I could really say about it I
will say that
it was uh one of the only times in my
life that I almost walked out of a movie
in the theater the only reason I didn't
is that I actually fell asleep and it's
it's and this is true it's the only move
I've ever felt I've missed like 45
minutes because I took a nice nap thank
God
all of this to say the sequel set to be
released in a couple of weeks is
guaranteed to be terrible now almost all
sequels are terrible even sequels to
good films but sequels to bad films are
doomed from the start because they're
building from a foundation of crap
and yet judging from the director's
recent public statements this sequel May
well be awful in ways that exceed our
wildest expectations so here's the story
from the New York Post it says James
Cameron has revealed that his
long-awaited Avatar sequel is rooted in
his personal issues quote I thought I'm
going to work out a lot of my stuff
artistically that I've gone through as a
parent of five kids Cameron 68 told The
Hollywood Reporter the overarching idea
is that the family is the Fortress it's
our greatest weakness and our greatest
strength I thought I can write the hell
out of this I know what it is to be the
a-hole dad
now if somehow a big budget sequel to
the most overrated film of all time made
as a means for the 68 year old director
to work out his personal issues seems
appealing to you then um wait until you
hear the rest of it
quote
reflecting back on his career which
includes highly publicized clashes with
Studio Executives Cameron said a lot of
things I did earlier I wouldn't do
career-wise and just risks that you take
as a wild testosterone poisoned young
man I always think of testosterone as a
toxin that you have to slowly work out
of your system
well good news James it seems that
you've mostly succeeded in that regard
nobody will accuse you of Having excess
testosterone but for the record
um testosterone is not a poison nor is
it a toxin nor is it something that you
want to work out of your system
it is in fact a hormone vital to growth
and vital to development which maintains
among other things your bone density
your muscle mass strength
of course the irony here is that if you
asked him you know about the subject
James Cameron as a Hollywood leftist
would almost certainly tell you that
he's a fan of gender affirmation drugs
and procedures which means that in his
world
testosterone is only a poison when it's
naturally produced
testosterone in the form of a drug given
to gender confused girls is uh is
wonderful
um and it's medically necessary and
affirmative but if it's naturally
produced by men then it's bad
and yet Cameron is really only guilty of
being overly honest here if anything
because this is how our society
generally treats men and boys
young men are poisoned by the toxin of
testosterone we're told that's the
essence of toxic masculinity after all
and you know it's it's true
that young men in particular can be wild
can be aggressive
um can be prone to risk-taking and
confrontation
testosterone indeed plays a big role in
that
but our approach as a culture should be
to help these boys and young men harness
their masculine energy not suppress it
or Purge themselves of it or drug it out
of them
but help them to develop the character
and discipline to funnel all of that
testosterone fueled aggression and
energy in a constructive and worthwhile
Direction
you know this is one of the many things
our society gets wrong when it comes to
men boys as they grow up
um they're not given proper Outlets
and most of the outlets that they once
had are being taken away
even things like the you know more
aggressive and and um sort of violent
games kids used to play on playgrounds
we don't play those games anymore
take all that away
they're not trained on how to harness
this energy they're not trained on how
to be men
they're so often deprived of competent
male role models
we are fearful of masculinity and so we
demand that boys essentially act like
girls and sometimes we literally try to
turn them into girls
and then as they get older and stronger
and become unruly and violent we
conclude that masculinity itself must be
the problem
rather than a lack of guidance a lack of
leadership a lack of moral formation
and the goal becomes as James Cameron
puts it to purge it masculinity to work
it out to eradicate it
and now he's made a movie about it
which you know you can watch if you
don't value your brain or your time or
your money
but I will decline the invitation for my
part and uh instead say to James Cameron
that you sir are
today canceled
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as you move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]